c'est un des plus grands rassemblements
de l'industrie du semi-conducteur le
salon semi-con plus de 700 exposants et
présentent leur plus récentes
d'innovations
c'est l'occasion pour les entreprises de
partout de brasser des affaires à Taïwan
plus grand producteur mondial dans le
domaine cette édition de semi-corne a
lieu au moment où l'industrie taïwanaise
tente de se faire rassurante
l'incertitude plane en raison de la
menace d'une invasion de Taïwan par la
Chine
Taïwan produit plus de 90% de toutes les
micropuces les plus avancées du monde
c'est semi-conducteur aussi petit que
deux nanomètres dans certains cas sont
essentiels en informatique et téléphonie
cellulaire ainsi que dans les transports
et la défense
la sécurité de Taïwan est un enjeu
important pour les États-Unis qui
veulent assurer leurs approvisionnements
de micro puces selon cette expert
il rappelle que les Américains ont
adopté une loi pour relancer leur propre
production
il cherche à former des partenariats
avec les entreprises taïwanaises dont le
géant mondial TSMC parallèlement la
Chine cherche aussi à augmenter sa
production mais certains craignent que
ça reste un motif pour envahir Taïwan
même s'il s'emparaît de nos usines
affirment se dirigeant il n'aurait pas
accès à notre expertise
risque d'invasion augmentation de la
production en Chine aux États-Unis mais
aussi en Europe dépression immenses pour
une industrie déjà frappée par une
pénurie de travailleurs qualifiés
avec l'arrivée de la 5G l'industrie des
semis conducteurs est plus indispensable
que jamais ce qui fait de l'avenir de
Taïwan un enjeu stratégique de premier
ordre ici Philippe Leblanc Radio-Canada